[Music]
jesse who was bundled up outside the
chicago courtroom today doubled down on
his denial that he hired these brothers
to stage an attack on him
there was no hoax he testified under
oath
telling a different version of events
the osun dyro brothers who claim it was
jesse who masterminded the attack and
paid them 3 500
to carry it out jesse claims the money
was for nutrition and workout advice you
ready to tell your truth i'm ready to do
what i got to do yeah yeah tell the
truth jesse also testified that he and
abel o'sundiro did drugs together and
had sexual encounters
this morning the prosecutor grilled
jesse about his appearance during the
gma interview i am forever changed
arguing that jesse had no noticeable
cuts or injuries the actor brushed it
off saying that was due to the makeup
and good lighting video by the way is a
major part of the prosecution's case
including this surveillance footage of
the brothers buying supplies for the
attack with the money they say jesse
gave them and this police body cam
footage from the night of the purported
attack you can see the rope around
jesse's neck
the 39 year old has pleaded not guilty
to six counts of disorderly conduct on
suspicion of making false reports to
police if convicted legal experts expect
he would receive probation and community
service
[Music]
you